Smart Lens Bless. Smart. Bless. Did you guys, did you guys see each other last night? Did you have a fun day? Yeah, we did. We had a little Grammy watch party. Yeah, it was really fun. Oh, you did, you did a full, I almost called in.
I almost did a call in because I miss everybody. I know, we miss you too. Well, I, we, you, I, you know, you're, when are you back? You're not back for what, two more months? No, I'm coming back tomorrow for a few days, but I'm going to miss you too. When are you back? You're not back for what, two more months? No, I'm coming back tomorrow for a few days, but I'm going to miss this weekend. I know this weekend is a thing up at the place for a friend and I can't go.
Yeah, I'm not there either. I can't go because you're going to go, right? No, I'm not, I can't. I go to London tomorrow. Oh, you're going to London tomorrow? You start tomorrow? No, no. No, but I going to London tomorrow? You start tomorrow. No, no, that, the other thing. No, but I mean, you start your journey, your process.
Do you have a complicated character you're playing in this next job, Shaunie? Not at all. No? So no homework, no process, no? I mean, yeah, because I'm a nerd, I do all that stuff still, but it's a... Wait, wait, give us a slight little window into that.
Well, it's the same. Look, it's the same. Can we say hi to your character? Yeah. Couldn't he make a visit with us? Sure. Let me just go ahead. Do you have a question for him?
Hey, good morning. How are you? Good morning. Oh, wow. He's a radio personality? No, he's a game show host. Oh, really? Oh, okay. And what's his name? I don't know his name., he's a game show host. Oh, really? Oh, okay. And what's his name?
I don't know his name, it's just a game show host. Oh, his name's just host, okay. So host, how are we doing today? I'm not doing this. It's so icky, I feel, I was just about to throw up. He gets shy, Will. He gets shy. Could you imagine?
Wait, let me quickly, and this is universal. You're going overseas, you're flying, you're taking a night flight. Are you gonna eat the meal on the plane? Will you eat on the plane? JB, will you eat the airline food? I gotta stay alive, yeah. I do like the airline food.
You do? It's gotten better over the last 50 years. I had heard a rumor that they stock it full of stuff to stop you from pooing. What, to stop you up, you mean? Yeah. There's a binding element to all plain food? Sure, a binding element,
because they don't want people like Sean and Scotty just gorging themselves and then all of a sudden, like, you know, creating a... And French kids. Yeah. Will, what newsletters are you into lately? I mean, are you like, where are you getting all this? Well, you know I still subscribe
to all my German poop mags. Remember those Air Mall magazines that used to be in the- Oh, I love them. They're so popular. Yeah, like the Hamacher Schlemmer section on it and stuff. You're like, of course I need a fucking ping pong table that folds up into a card table. Did you ever buy anything from one of those?
I think like a dog door. Do they still have barf bags in the back of the seats? I haven't looked for a while. They do because I chew a lot of gum. But isn't that interesting? Like a lot of people don't throw up like they did in the 70s. Now nobody throws up for a while. They do because I chew a lot of gum. But isn't that interesting? Like a lot of people don't throw up like they did in the 70s. Now nobody throws up on a plane.
You think that people throw up less? Yeah, on a plane. On a plane, like when have you heard, seen somebody throw up on a plane? Right, it used to be on every flight. Have you ever thrown up on a plane? Sure I have. I did.
Too much Kiwi once. Yeah, I threw up, I threw up, I got on a plane, I was super hungover, I was about 18. Okay. I'm not kidding. Well you threw up from hungover, not the plane. Yeah, not the plane. But I remember vividly, we were taxiing out,
leaving Toronto, and just as we start to increase speed, I go, I'm gonna need my bag. Somebody had sealed it with a piece of gum. Can I just say, it is gross. I filled it. I filled the bag. I had to get another, I had to hold it as we took off. And I go, I'm gonna throw it in another bag.
Oh my. It was a, actually, it should be noted, I threw up in the airport terminal before I got on the plane. I was walking in the old Toronto terminal number one, so it shows you how long it was. And I remember walking to the gate, I guess, from having checked in and being like, oh boy, I gotta go. And I ran and there was a, I opened a door, I thought there was a bathroom, no bathroom,
but there was a door and I opened it and it's just the stairs, like the raw stairs going between the floors. And you're like, oh, that'll do. And there were people coming and I literally go, whoa! And they moved and they threw up down the stairs. Just a big cascade. Projectile.
Yeah. Projectile. That is something. Isn't that unreal? It was so gross. God, that's funny. Have either of you guys thrown up in a while? No, not in a long time.
About 10 years ago, I was doing reshoots on Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles, and I was like, I woke up one morning and I started throwing and going. It was a two-part affair. Everything was happening at once. And then we were like, we were on reshoots and we had to go and I went and everybody,
like most other people on set had gotten, this bug was going through. And at one point I was working, shooting a scene with somebody and they go, the director goes, okay, well, okay. He's like, okay, just come out here and then you just gotta run across the parking lot. I go, dude, I'm not running anywhere.
Because if I run one foot. One foot, it's all over. Something's gonna open. What was the movie? Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles. Wonderful. Which is a great segue to our guest. I really enjoyed that film.
Oh, gee. That's a callback. I love it. My guest today has been a close friend of mine for decades. She's... She's... Get to the good part! He's so far from the stage. I can't believe it.
Guys, who is the guest? Before I go. Fuck me. Thank God I'm crying. Me too. Okay. Now listen. We got it.
Come on, guys. You know what I think, I truly believe when you laugh that deep, you're killing cancer. I truly believe that. I think you're right. I think you're right. All right, well we got to explain to her what the joke is so she's in on it. All right, so she's a very good friend of mine.
She's a Peabody, an Emmy award winning journalist and producer, as well as a devoted mother, grandmother, and friend to so many. She's the person I go to for advice about literally anything. She's the author of seven New York Times bestselling books. Seven, I've been trying to get her to read them to me.
Born in Chicago, just like me, but the former first lady of California, which is only slightly like me. It's the luminescent and brilliant and wonderful friend, Maria Shriver. Oh, Maria Shriver. I got it. I got it before you said it.
Good morning. You had to sit through all Shriver. I got it. I got it before you said it. Okay. Good morning. You had to sit through all of that. I can't believe that. I can't believe I'm going, I'm throwing, the blowing. I just am like, oh, I feel so at home. I have four brothers. Why did you say yes to this?
A lot is happening. A lot is happening. You grew up like that. I grew up like that. I still live like that. So I have four brothers, so this was not a shock to me at all. I actually really enjoyed it. They're also dingbats, just like us, huh?
Forgive us, forgive us. The barf bag, I've sat next to people like that. So I have been so jealous of your friendship with Shawnee for so long. I hear you're just the greatest ever. This is the first day of our friendship. I'm very excited. The first day of our friendship. I know I've been asking Sean to invite me on this show
since the very beginning, and he wouldn't invite me. No, no way. He wouldn't invite me. He would never invite me. Yeah, I don't know why. No, wait a minute. Why, never. He said we have to start with all the famous people. Sean, no, no, no. No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no.
since the very beginning, and he wouldn't invite me. No, no way. He wouldn't invite me. He would never invite me. Yeah, I don't know why. No, wait a minute. Why, never. He said we have to start with all the famous people. Sean, no, no, no. No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no. No, no, no, no. No, no, no. No, no, no. No, no, no.
No, no, no. No, no, no. No, no, no. No, no, no. No, no, no. No, no, no. No, no, no. No, no, no. No, no, no. No, no, no. No, no, no. No, no, no. No, no, no. You just saying that about me? Oh my God. What are you doing?
I said to you, I said do you want to come on? You said, what am I going to talk about? What would I ever talk about? This was five years ago when we started, and now you're like, can I come on the show? I'm like, of course you can. I'm like, because people all say to me, why has Sean never had you on his show?
It's so weird. I go, I know, it's so weird. It is weird. It is weird. We can talk to you about anything, though, is what I love about you. You can tackle any issue. Yes, that's why I can can talk to you about anything, though, is what I love about you. You can tackle any issue. Yes, that's why I can't wait to talk about 10,000 things.
But you said to me, I said what I'm so excited about is the only show I've ever gone on where I haven't prepared at all, because you told me not to prepare at all. Correct, yeah. So I didn't brush my hair, I had no makeup. Yeah, because we're not. Anything.
Nothing. We're not filming this, it's just audio. It's a podcast, you know what a podcast is. But I didn't prepare. Please don't explain to know what a podcast is. Yeah, but I didn't prepare. Please don't explain to her what a podcast is. Thank you Will, thank you. I mean my God. This is a bridge to a far.
Really, oh my God. It's insulting, insulting. It's something I can sit here with three men. I don't know what's that about. We're gonna talk about that too. All right, so. Three men? Yes.
You are, okay, first of all, you're one of the most special people in my life. I love you very much. I love you too. I've known you for a very long time. How'd you guys meet, by the way? How did this start? It started in 2001-ish, around there.
And I used to date somebody that knew Maria, and that's how we are introduced. Oh, all right. God, okay. Yeah. So, my first question, go ahead, Willie. Oh, all right. God, okay. Yeah. So my first question, go ahead. No, you go ahead with your first question. Line it up.
I was just gonna say, because you've been that to me in so many things to me and you're always the person I go to for advice and blah, blah, blah, who is that for you? Good question. I often go to my kids, actually. I have deep conversations with my kids. Depends what I'm looking for advice for.
I have four brothers, so I usually go to them. I would say I go to my four brothers, depending on the subject matter. So each brother's a little different. They have a different level of expertise in different areas. But I often go to probably my brothers, my kids, sometimes my son-in-law now, I go to him.
We love your son-in-law. We love him. Yeah, you love him. Yeah, I love him too. So for my sister, that's Chris Pratt, my sister who doesn't, right? Yeah. We adore Chris, we love him, we play golf with him sometimes,
we like to hang out with him, he's the funniest, he's such a naturally funny guy. Yeah, he imitates you guys playing golf. Oh, does he? Uh-oh. Yeah, he does. It must take a while. It's not pretty.
It's not pretty, no. It's not pretty. Throw your ball into the woods, and that's an imitation of me playing golf. Maria, what area lately do you find yourself reaching out for advice on? What area in this crazy ass world is confusing you most? Right now.
Well, how to stay engaged and not be mean in the engagement. How to get above all of the rancor and still stay in trying to make the world better. Still trying to figure out how to keep your voice measured, really good word, how to keep myself focused on what I'm trying to focus on and not get mixed up in what everybody wants to get you mixed up in.
Sometimes I do that well and sometimes I don't. Sometimes I ask my priest, actually, depending on what the subject is. But... Well, you know, lately, I'm not to get, sorry to cut you off, but not to get too political, but it does seem that lately, but lately, lately there seems to be this pressure on one side to kind of take the gloves off
and meet the other side where they're at, and I'm wondering if you have a perspective on that. Yes, I don't. Not to get political. I try not to do that. Not to get political. I try not to do that. I try not to get into that at all.
I try to just figure out what do I want to change in the world, what's my issue, what are the one or two things I want to do, and I try to just figure out what do I want to change in the world, what's my issue, what are the one or two things I want to do, and I try to stay on that and really focus on that. I have a spiritual practice that helps me in the morning stay focused, and I try to talk about my own emotional sobriety, and I try to think about, okay, how is this gonna put my own ball down the court?
I work on Alzheimer's research a lot. I work on women's health. And so I try to kind of focus on those things. And I try not to kind of attack people personally, which is always a challenge. I think that's really smart. I love that. I love you talking about your spiritual practice
you do in the morning and your emotional sobriety. I really love that idea. Yeah, I've never heard of that. And do what you can in the immediate and be present in your life right here. Yeah, I also try to follow people that I admire who are inspiring, who I respect. And there's a great guy named Father Richard Rohr
who has a school, it's called Contemplatives in Action, and I think that that's a really cool concept to be in the world, but to be contemplative in it, to bring about change in the world, but how you go about doing it, I think we think all the time we have to be angry and divisive and partisan to bring about any change. And I don't subscribe to that.
I think that we can walk into the world and be determined to be focused, but we don't have to be angry and mean about it. It's kind of like, how do you fight, so to speak. And we always think you have to fight rough and tumble and mean, and I think you can fight for an issue in a very focused way, but not a mean device. Yeah, for sure.
So you're so accomplished in so many different areas and mediums, and how are you, you mentioned Alzheimer's and women's health, are you, how are you, you mentioned Alzheimer's and women's health. Are you, how are you pointing all those super powers of yours right now? What are you, where are you enjoying putting all that stuff? We're going to get into that. She's got a wonderful magazine.
Yes. Although I just, I love, last year I worked with President Biden and we started the very first White House initiative on women's health and research. That was big news. That was huge news. It was really big because there had never been, believe it or not, in this country,
a White House initiative on women's health and research. And there had never been, we only spend 10% of the NIH budget on women's health and research. So we're so far behind and that's been a passion. Even though they're more than 50% of the population. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, and so that was a really big passion project
and we did a lot of great work before he left. And so that's something that's still really important to me because we're really far behind and for women of all ages. And especially if you're, you know, the thing, one of the things I learned from you too is the, all of the statistics about women's health and women's Alzheimer's specifically, because I've been afflicted with it in my family,
you have with your dad and my mom. And so one of the things, you know, you always said, or in your research and your education about it, you've said it's really important to, as you get older, learn an instrument, learn a language, force yourself to remain social, even when you, because you want to be more sedentary when you get older.
You're just like, I don't want to go out, I don't want to do anything. But it's so important to challenge your brain as you get older, because nobody knows if you're going to get this all time. Are you thinking about starting? Yeah, I'm going to think about starting. Sean's like Broadway play show, I mean, talk about memory.
Yeah, I know. Talk about an instrument. I went there and I'm of course, we've talked about it. We've talked about it ad nauseam. Would you Maria, would you say that like staying and asked and I point this towards my partners here, would you think that staying in your house
364 days a year, do you think that's healthy? No, that's not healthy. I don't think you do that though. Well, it depends on what you're doing inside that house. What are you doing inside that house? Go, you go first. Me? Well, listen, when you talk about an instrument,
does a remote control count? Yeah, you gotta learn how to manipulate an instrument, does a remote control count? Shh. Yeah, you gotta learn how to manipulate. Yeah, I can't do that. I have to call my son all the time. And he's like, I've shown you this before, Mommy. I said, I know, but I can't remember. Could you show it again?
I was at your house for dinner last Thursday, and this big thing, we're watching TV, and this big thing comes on the screen. And we're like, how do you get rid of this? She's like, it'll go away. It'll just go away. I'm like, no, it's not going away. Just leave it alone, it'll go away.
It'll go away. And did it go away? Did it go away? It actually did. Okay, it went away. It went away. It said, update now, update later, press here. And Sean's like, move it, move it.
So I can watch the three of you. That's what he kept saying. He's like, I want to mirror the three of us. I'm like, just wait a minute, I can watch the three of you. That's what he keeps doing. He's like, I want to mirror the three of us. I'm like, just wait a minute. We'll watch the three of you. He goes, do you want to watch one version of us or do you want to watch 10 different clips of us? I say, oh, I want to watch 10 different clips.
That's all I want to do tonight. You're hijacked. Yeah, is watch the three of you. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Wait, go back to this. I've never heard you say emotional sobriety. Yeah, can you explain to these guys
and anybody who listens that you go, I don't remember what it's called, but you go to a place every August, is it? Or something where, or you used to at least, where you go off the grid every August, is it, or something, or you used to, at least, where you go off the grid and you, what is that place? It was like a spirituality place or something? No, actually, no, that's totally wrong.
Great work, Sean. We're done, thank you. Yeah, what a good way to listen. What a good place. I go to the last, I go to a place where my emotional sobriety is challenged, and that's, I go home to Hyannisport, where all my cousins are. Oh. I need a practice. Oh, are we not, you donety is challenged and that's, I go home to Hyannisport where all my cousins are.
I need a practice. Oh, are we not, you don't wanna talk about that place, that other thing you do? What other thing I do? That thing that we used to go to where you had to put your cell phone down and you didn't have to, it was like a retreat. Oh, I went to, yeah, I've been to a lot of retreats.
That's Hoffman, that's the Hoffman. That's what it is. Oh, I wanna go there so badly. I keep hearing about that place, what is that? Yeah, so I went there. You're not equipped, JB, you can't do it. No, I can't do it. It's too intense, it's too intense.
And I'm going back for a tune-up again. I'm a big believer in exploring yourself. That's kind of why I wrote this new book on poetry and reflection. And I'm a big- Yes, called I Am Maria. Yes, I am, and there's a long story behind that. But anyway, I'm a big... Yes, called I am Maria. Yes, I am. And there's a long story behind that. But anyway, I'm a big believer in trying to understand why you may feel dissatisfied, why you may feel stuck, why you may feel angry, why do you erupt here, there and everywhere?
What is going on inside of you? You erupt. Sorry. Sorry, that just came out of nowhere. These are the bits. The listeners love the bits. I feel like I'm at home. I feel like I'm so at home.
I've asked Sean to bring you guys to dinner one night. Oh, we'd love to. Sean, you got the invite. He's never mentioned it. Relay that. No. I'm not kidding. He's never said that.
Sean, you said, remember I said when we did those questions that lovers do, marriage couples do, and so I asked Sean to do it with me. And one of the things was, you said, remember I said when we did those questions that lovers do, marriage couples do, and so I asked Shawn to do it with me. And one of the things was, you know, you had to go through what do we like about each other, how do we want the other person to grow. He had done it with Scottie, so I said, can you do it with me?
And then one of the things I said to you at the end is I want you to invite me to meet your friends. He's never mentioned it. All right, I'm gonna make it happen. He's never mentioned it. He's never mentioned it. All right, I'm gonna make it happen. I'm gonna make it happen. He's never mentioned it. He's never mentioned it, I know. Here's the thing, and I might be divulging,
this might be too much information, but I've recently been made aware of the term of being, or the idea of being intimate with yourself. And that's not what you think, JB. So it's- Damn it. I thought we were gonna hear some technique. No, no, no, no.
It's, it's, it's, this idea about learning how to be intimate with yourself is something, is a process that I've been sort of going through recently and it's been really revealing and really tough to do. It's a new practice for me. How do you do that? Well, it's about, well, it's a form of therapy that I'm sort of going through.
It's part of the therapy that I've been experiencing of late and it's about going back and being honest with myself about things and about where I've been and about allowing myself to feel certain things that I was potentially avoiding for a long time, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera. Yeah. And it's good for men to do that and Maria. Well, you can't, and the idea, yes, it's good for men.
And the idea is that you can't have real intimacy with somebody else if you cannot be intimate with yourself. Bingo. Oh, that's interesting. Yeah, which I was like, oh, all right. I love that. I love that you're doing that because I think it's, I do that through writing
and sometimes I've done it through therapy, but I find that when I write and if I write early in the morning and I write when it's quiet, and that's what this book kind of is a lot of poetry. It's kind of on the stream of consciousness, just allowing stuff to come up. And you find that there's a whole other person
living in there or whole other voice that wants to speak, which is really fascinating. Yeah. It's been interesting. And also I was thinking about when you said, JB, I think you, one of you did, who are the people that you go to, Maria, to talk to about things and what are the conversations?
And there is somebody, we have a mutual friend who I go to, other than these guys, who I talk to about a lot of these things, who is my buddy Clay, whom I think you know. Yeah. I go to Clay too. And Clay's my guy. Yeah, I love that.
And he's one of my best friends, and he's my brother, I love him. And he's been incredible to me on so many levels. I love that, yeah. Oh, I love that. That's so beautiful. My brother now goes to Clay too. Yes.
That's so beautiful. My brother now goes to Clay too. Yes. Clay is really great at reminding you who you are. At telling you what he sees and reassuring you that that voice that's telling you all those other things is wrong and that what he sees is what other people see. And I think we all need a friend like that, actually.
Sean, you're like that with me, right? You tell me what you see, you remind me when I go down a hole. They often, in lyricals, sometimes people call that an anum cara. There's a book about that that John O'Donoghue, the poet, wrote called the anum cara, which means soul friend, it's Gaelic, right?
It means soul friend, and it's somebody who is a very intimate friend. It can be a sexual person, but it can often very not be at all. And it's just someone who sees you, who reflects back to you who you are, who tells you, who's honest with you, who tells you what they see.
And reassures you that you're on the path and also is honest enough to tell you when you've fallen off of it. And can remind you that you can get back up. That's really, and yeah, Sean, you hear that. It's an intimate friend, right? It can be sexual and that's a call, it's a gay lick. It's like a salt lick. But actually, I think a Gaelic. Yeah. So, so. It's like a Salt Lick, but it's Gaelic.
But actually, I think I met, you know what, Marie, I met your brother at Clay's birthday. You met me at Clay's birthday. We had met before though. Yeah, but we talked there. We talked there, but I didn't want to say that we met there because you don't remember the first time we met, but I do, we had met.
Oh, Sean, Sean, let's you and I take a quick five. I didn't want to put you on the spot. Tell me where did we meet the first time? Years ago at Sean's house, and Sean, this is over 20 years ago, Sean had a card game in a big poker night at his house. Do you remember that? It was like...
It was so long ago. It was over 20 years ago. Is that another thing that I wasn't at? No, you were there actually. You were, you had switched numbers. You had changed phone numbers. No, no. No, no.
No, this was like 25 years ago. Yeah, it was a long time ago. Yeah, we were still friends then. It's cool. We'll double back on this after we sign off. Anyway, anyway, yeah, you're right. But it is great having those kinds of people in your life. Yeah, I love that.
And I like these guys, we have the same thing. It's not holding your feet to the fire, but it's the ability to go, hey, this is what's going on and being unafraid to say, hey, have you thought about this in a way that's kind and constructive and safe? And that exercise that Maria was talking about where we wrote each other, like, you know, good things, things to work on, whatever, blah, blah,
blah, I said to her, you remember mine? The big one to you. Was, hey, do you think you could introduce me to people when I come over your house? Because she, your whole life has been so huge, filled with so many people constantly 24 seven in your house, out of your, it's like a revolving door of all these people that come in and out.
And I'll see these people and he'll be like, yeah, that's Martha. So anyway, come over. And I'm like, who is that? And I'll be sitting next, like having a hamburger next to somebody. And I'm like, I have no idea who this person is. And you just assume that I know them.
And are you bringing your own hamburgers? Are you bringing the burgers with you? He does bring his own dessert though. He does bring his own dessert though. He does bring his own dessert. He sure does. He does. Is it any wonder why his husband is a diabetic? No.
Shawn's got a trunk full of treats. I bring my own desserts because as wonderful as you are to feed me, a lot of the times the desserts are gluten free, sugar free, bubbly free. But that's because of Scotty. Why are you doing a funny voice? I'm doing that because of Scotty. Oh, I didn't know that.
Out of respect, Sean. Out of respect, thank you. I'm like you, she's not trying to kill your husband. Right. I love his husband, he's so calm, so steady. He's the best, we love Scotty. We love Scotty, Scotty is the best. Maria, you touched on going back home
出于敬意，西恩。出于敬意，谢谢你。我和你一样，她不是想谋杀你丈夫。没错。我爱她的丈夫，他那么冷静，那么稳重。他是最棒的，我们爱斯科蒂。我们爱斯科蒂，斯科蒂是最棒的。玛丽亚，你刚才提到了回老家
and visiting your family and needing to sort of arm yourself, if you will, with the spiritual program. The idea of growing up with that kind of, and continued sort of being part of a family that is under that kind of scrutiny, what does that do? Because we all have sort of- Well, tell Tracy, like the,
探亲，并且需要用精神项目来武装自己，如果你愿意这么说的话。带着那种背景长大，而且一直作为这种严格审视下的家族的一员，这会带来什么影响？因为我们都有某种——好吧，告诉特雷西，比如，
so your dad is Sergeant, the great Sergeant Shriver, your mom is Eunice Kennedy, who is the sister of JFK, and you're the niece, and blah, blah, blah, okay. I am Maria. I am Maria, right, and that's what I wanted to talk about. I am Maria. And that's what I wanted to talk about.
所以你爸爸是警长，伟大的施赖弗警长，你妈妈是尤尼斯·肯尼迪，她是约翰·F·肯尼迪的妹妹，你是外甥女，等等等等，好吧。我是玛丽亚。我是玛丽亚，对，这正是我想要谈论的。我是玛丽亚。这正是我想要谈论的。
You can find it on paperback, or on- She is Maria. I am Maria. Maria. I am Maria. I am Maria. I am Maria. She is Maria! I'm Maria! Maria! I'm Maria! I'm Maria! The daughter, the niece, the cousin, the this, the that. And you're like, I'm Maria.
你可以在平装书里找到，或者在——她是玛丽亚。我是玛丽亚。玛丽亚。我是玛丽亚。我是玛丽亚。我是玛丽亚。她是玛丽亚！我是玛丽亚！玛丽亚！我是玛丽亚！我是玛丽亚！女儿、外甥女、表妹、这个、那个。而你会想，我是玛丽亚。
But that's what I wanted to talk about, about the Hoffman's place, is a guy came out, remember this conversation was like, three or five years ago. Oh, do I talk to you or do I talk to, I mean, or Will, Will asked me a question or do I go to you? Do I get the will first?
但这就是我想要谈论的，关于霍夫曼训练营的地方，有个家伙走出来，记住这个对话大概是三五年前的事。哦，我是跟你说还是跟，我是说，还是威尔，威尔问了我一个问题，还是我该去找你？我应该先找威尔吗？
Thank you, Maria. Thank you. I just don't know, where do I go? I just first like to deal with Will. Welcome to Smart Lips. Because I'm your guest or should I go to you? I. Thank you. I just don't know, where do I go? I just first like to deal with Will. Welcome to Smart List. Because I'm your guest or should I go to you? But it has to do with Will, what Will's about to say. Okay.
谢谢你，玛丽亚。谢谢。我只是不知道，我该去找谁？我只是想先和威尔谈谈。欢迎来到《聪明简史》。因为我是你的嘉宾，还是我应该去找你？我。谢谢。我只是不知道，我该去找谁？我只是想先和威尔谈谈。欢迎来到《聪明简史》。因为我是你的嘉宾，还是我应该去找你？但这跟威尔有关，跟威尔接下来要说的话有关。好吧。
So the reason I brought up the Hoffman thing is because you shared with me that part of your journey at Hoffman was a guy came up to you and immediately started asking you about your lineage. Right? And you're like, hang on, and it upset you because you're like, wait, my name is Maria Shriver, I am my own person, I have my own accomplishments,
所以我提起霍夫曼的事，是因为你跟我分享过，你在霍夫曼的经历中，有一个人走到你面前，立刻开始打听你的家世。对吧？然后你会想，等等，这让你很不高兴，因为你想，等等，我叫玛丽亚·施赖弗，我有我自己的人格，我有我自己的成就，
I have a family, I'm a mom, all these things that you are without the Kennedys, right? And then you had an epiphany that you shared with me, you're like, wait, but part of me is that, and to shun it is wrong, right? And so, and then I know that's kind of a prep to what Will's probably about to ask you. What was it like?
我有一个家庭，我是一位母亲，抛开肯尼迪家族的光环，你所拥有的这一切，对吧？然后你顿悟了，你跟我分享过，你想，等等，但我的一部分确实包含那些，而回避它是错误的，对吧？所以，然后我知道这算是对威尔接下来要问的问题的一个铺垫。那是什么感觉？
Well, I had already asked her, what is it like? Do you feel, but yes, sure, that's adjacent to what I'm saying, which is, yeah, that's a- I'm right here, yeah. A Jason. A Jason Abatement. A Jason Abatement. Yeah, my new mobile company.
好吧，我已经问过她了，那是什么感觉？你觉得，但是没错，当然，这跟我刚才说的话挨着，也就是，对，那是个——我就在这儿，对。挨着（Jason）。杰森减免（Jason Abatement）。杰森减免。对，我的新移动公司。
Yeah. Yeah, yeah. I think it's going to do well. I think it will. Yeah. It's funny. But talk about that. It's a lot. It's a lot, actually. But I find after doing a lot of work, I find myself now in a really good place about it. Well, because, and the reason I'm, what's interesting is, you know, you hear people
对。对，对。我觉得它会干得不错。我也觉得会。对。真搞笑。不过聊聊那个吧。这确实挺沉重的。其实挺沉重的。但我发现在做了大量自我剖析之后，我现在觉得心态好多了。好吧，因为，我之所以，有趣的是，你知道，你会听到有人
who are, who have made names of themselves as a, whatever it is, name the discipline. And then people say, and if they say, well, it's tough being in this position, the critics say, well, fuck it, that's the price you pay for being famous. And they say that, right? So you can't complain. In a lot of ways, even though you've had so many great accomplishments that you've forged on your own, you were born into it.
他们通过自己的努力成了某种意义上的名人，不管是什么领域，说出他们的专业。然后人们会说，如果他们说，在这个位置上很难混，评论家就会说，去你的，这就是成名付出的代价。他们会这么说，对吧？所以你不能抱怨。在很多方面，尽管你通过自己的努力取得了那么多伟大的成就，但你是生在这样的家庭里的。
You didn't have a choice is the truth, right? Right, yeah, but I think we all have a choice about how we wanna conduct ourselves in that experience, right? And I think what I tried to do was outwork my lineage, which was a mistake. And I thought like, oh, if I get accomplished, if I do all these things,
实话实说，你没得选，对吧？对，没错，但我觉得我们对于自己想在那段经历中表现得怎么样，都是有选择的，对吧？我觉得我试图做的是，用加倍的工作来超越我的家世，这是一个错误。我当时想，哦，如果我取得了成就，如果我做了所有这些事情，
then you won't be introducing me by whose daughter I am, whose cousin I am, whose niece I am, and won't be talking to me only about those things. And that was a driver, certainly, but I think it was unrealistic because I came to understand, like, I'm never gonna outwork that. I'm never gonna outperform that.
那么你们就不会再用我是谁的女儿、谁的表妹、谁的外甥女来介绍我，也不会只跟我谈论那些事情了。这当然是一个动力，但我认为这不切实际，因为我渐渐明白，我永远无法在工作上超越这个背景。我永远无法在表现上超越这个背景。
I'm never gonna out that, right? So to speak. So getting to a place where like, okay, wait a minute, let me figure out how to accept that, how to be happy when people come up and that's all they want to talk to me about. And then just try to understand that I have my own practice, I have friends who understand who I am,
我永远无法摆脱这个，对吧？可以说是这样。所以，当你走到这一步，觉得“好吧，等一下，让我琢磨琢磨怎么接受它，怎么在别人走过来只聊这些的时候保持开心”。然后试着去理解，我有我自己的事业，我有懂我的朋友，
who love me for me, and that I can't change everybody's opinion. Like I go through the airport or I sit down and that's what all people want to talk to me about. I just go, okay, now I understand that. I just let that be and I don't get mad at them. Yeah, yeah. But it's so funny, like growing up in my generation
他们因为我是我而爱我，我无法改变所有人的看法。就像我走过机场或者坐下来，所有人只想跟我聊这些。我只会想，好吧，现在我明白了。我只是顺其自然，不会对他们生气的。对，对。但真搞笑，比如在我的成长年代里，
and seeing you on TV all the time, I would never ever think of talking to you about that because I grew up seeing you as Maria Shriver only. Yeah, exactly. Even more famous than any of sort of any Kennedy lineage could put on someone. Like you were extremely successful in carving your own name, your own position, your own profile.
经常在电视上看到你，我绝对永远不会想跟你聊那些，因为我从小到大只把你当成玛丽亚·施赖弗。对，完全正确。甚至比肯尼迪家族背景能带给任何人的名气还要大。就像你在开创自己的名字、自己的地位、自己的形象方面非常成功。
But people want to talk to me about the other. Right. Yeah, well, yeah, exactly. And so I think it's just getting to a place of understanding that, that that's part of you and not fighting it, and then just trying to figure out, okay, what do I wanna do, which brings me back, what are the issues that I care about?
但人们就是想跟我聊别的东西。对。对，没错，确实如此。所以我觉得这只是达到了一种理解的境界，意识到那是你的一部分，不要去抗拒它，然后试着弄清楚，好吧，我想做点什么，这就把我带回了原点，我关心的问题是什么？
And not feeling like I'm not performing if I'm not running for president. That's kind of how I grew up. Like, if you're not gonna run for that, get out of the way. Go to the back of the room. So I had to go like, okay. And my mother was also a total force of nature.
不会觉得自己如果不去竞选总统，就是在混日子。我差不多就是这么长大的。就像，如果你不打算去竞选那个，那就让开。退到房间后面去。所以我不得不调整心态，好吧。而且我母亲也是一个绝对的狠角色。
She certainly was. Quite a tough woman. And she also was not interested in hearing any complaint about anything. So I wanted to ask you about that because the few lunches I had with her, and you, I'd be sitting, she scared the shit out of me. I'd be sitting there having lunch,
她当然是。是个相当强悍的女人。而且她也对听到任何关于任何事情的抱怨毫无兴趣。所以我本想问你这个，因为我和她以及你一起吃过的几次午餐里，我坐在那儿，她吓死我了。我坐在那儿吃午餐，
and we had a couple good laughs, like you and me. Yeah, she's funny. Yeah, she's funny. But you're right, she's very guarded, or whatever, however you want to describe it. And you are one of the best mothers I've ever witnessed. Like the rules that you put in place and the boundaries and the love
我们也有过几次开怀大笑的时候，就像你和我一样。对，她很搞笑。对，她很搞笑。但你说得对，她防备心很重，或者随便你怎么形容吧。而你是我见过的最棒的母亲之一。比如你设立的规矩、划定的界限以及爱，
and all of those things as a mother was incredible to witness. But did you recognize that in your mom that she is this kind of like you said, force of nature in an emotional way? Did you find that, okay, well, like all of us, we gotta take the good stuff from our parents and the stuff that maybe we don't wanna take and how did you find that, okay, well, like all of us, we gotta take the good stuff from our parents and the stuff that maybe we don't wanna take, and how did you find that balance?
作为一个母亲，所有这些都让人惊叹。但你有没有意识到，在你母亲身上，她就像你说的，在情感上是一个狠角色？你有没有发现，好吧，像我们所有人一样，我们得从父母身上吸收好的部分，以及那些我们可能不想吸收的部分，你是怎么找到那个平衡的？
And were you aware of how she was? Well, I was aware she terrified everybody, and she terrified me too. So I mean, so I was aware of that. I was aware that she was formidable, and I stood up, as I said, every time she walked in the room till the day she died. Both my parents, I was raised that way.
你当时意识到她是什么样的人了吗？好吧，我知道她吓坏了所有人，她也吓坏了我。所以，我是意识到了这一点的。我知道她是个令人敬畏的人，正如我所说，从她走进房间的那天起，直到她去世，她每次进来我都起立。我父母都是这样，我是这么被抚养长大的。
My grandparents, my parents, they're in charge, they're running the roost, and they had really high expectations. And my brothers, so they were very clear about their expectations. So, and if you were not doing them, well, you just did not do them. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. How did that transfer into your style of parenting?
我的祖父母，我的父母，他们才是主心骨，他们当家作主，他们对我们有很高的期望。还有我的兄弟们，所以他们对我们的期望非常明确。所以，如果你没有做到，好吧，你就是没有做到。对，对，对，对。这后来是如何转化为你的育儿风格的？
Like my dad was super duper strict and I found that I kind of went the other direction to a certain extent. Like I wanted my kids to feel a little bit more of a friendship with me than I had with my dad, but then I also recognized that I had this big authority figure, this disciplinarian in front of me was very good for me,
比如我爸爸超级无敌严格，我发现自己在某种程度上走向了相反的方向。就像我希望我的孩子们觉得跟我在一起比我跟我爸在一起时更有尼古拉的朋友感，但后来我也意识到，我面前有这样一个巨大的权威人物、一个严厉的纪律执行者，其实对我是很有好处的，
gave me a lot of structure. And so I thought, oh, maybe I'm doing a disservice to my kids, so I kind of tried to tack back. Like how did you find a balance there? Well, I tried to kind of take a lot of the things, both my parents instilled in me, but I tried to be softer in that I tried to say I love you. I tried to touch them and hold them and nurture them.
给了我很多结构和规范。所以我想，哦，我是不是在对孩子们做无用功，所以我试着往回调整。比如你是怎么在其中找到平衡的？好吧，我试图吸取我父母灌输给我的很多东西，但我试着变得更温柔一些，我会试着说我爱你们。我试着去触碰他们、拥抱他们、滋养他们，
And, you know, I guess really touch, you know, hold them. And, you know, I think my, but I also have, and through Hoffman and other work, understood that my mother, you know, asking my mother to give me something that wasn't given to her was unfair. Right, right, right. And so she didn't grow up being held
而且，我猜真的去触碰、拥抱他们。而且，我觉得我的，但我也通过霍夫曼和其他工作意识到，我的母亲，要求我母亲给予她从未得到的东西是不公平的。对，对，对。所以她长大的过程中并没有得到那种拥抱，
like that she didn't grow up being held like that. She didn't grow up being, she was loved in a different way. And I felt loved, but not like how I would look at other people's mothers. Right, right, right. It wasn't the same thing, you know? We'll be right back. And now back to the show.
她长大的过程中没有得到那种对待。她没有在那种环境下长大，她是以另一种方式被爱的。我觉得自己被爱了，但跟我看别人家的母亲时的感觉不一样。对，对，对。那不是一回事，你知道吗？我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。
Was that a big moment for you when you started to, I remember certain things about, not forgiving your parents, but when you have an understanding and appreciation of what it is, what their limitations are because of how they were brought up, et cetera. First of all, it happens later in life than you wish. You wish it would happen when you were 18. Right. You know, what was that like for you? Was that a sort of a watershed moment in your life?
当你开始有这种体会时，这算不算是你生命中的一个重大时刻？我记得关于某些事情，倒不是原谅父母，而是当你对他们的局限性——由于他们的成长经历等原因造成的局限性——有了理解和欣赏时。首先，这比你希望的要发生在更晚的人生阶段。你希望在你18岁时就能明白。对。你知道，那对你来说是什么感觉？那算不算是你生命中的一个分水岭时刻？
Yeah, and it continued to be in multiple ways. And even after my mother passed away, it was, I continued to learn about her and continue to change my relationship with her in death as well and trying to understand how she was raised, what she was up against. My mother, she dressed in men's pants, she carried a briefcase, she smoked cigars,
是的，而且在许多方面它一直在延续。甚至在我母亲去世后也是如此，我继续了解她，在生死两界中不断改变我与她的关系，试着理解她是如何长大的，她面对的是什么。我母亲，她穿着男士裤子，拎着公文包，抽雪茄，
she only hung out with men. She'd have, like our table was filled with men and when like they would bring their wives and maybe wives would go into one corner, she'd always go with the men. She had her cigar out, she'd have her pencils in her hair and she was like on it. She was like not messing around at all.
她只跟男人混在一起。她会有，比如我们的桌子周围坐满了男人，当他们带妻子来的时候，也许妻子们会去一个角落，她总是和男人们坐在一起。她叼着雪茄，头发里插着铅笔，一副全神贯注的样子。她是一点也不跟你开玩笑的。
So I was like, okay, is that a woman? Is that the way you're supposed to do it? I don't know. She was very competitive, hyper competitive, tried to beat all her children, beat everybody who came around. And so she was- And challenging, not physically.
所以我当时就想，好吧，那是一个女人吗？那就是你应该做的事吗？我不知道。她非常有竞争意识，超级好胜，试图击败她所有的孩子，击败身边的每一个人。所以她——而且很有挑战性，不是体力的。
Very challenging. Yeah, not physically. Beat competitively. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Not beat them. Yeah. Thank you, Sean. You're welcome.
非常有挑战性。对，不是体力的。在竞争中击败。对，对，对。不是打他们。对，对。谢谢你，西恩。不客气。
That's on you. But I admired that. That's how she created the Special Olympics. That's how she created change in the field of people with intellectual disabilities. She willed it into action and she stomped the halls of Capitol Hill and she forced her brother when he was president and her other brothers when they were in the Senate to change laws. And she was relentless and her other brothers when they were in the Senate to change laws, and she was relentless, and that created tremendous change.
那是你的问题。但我很佩服这一点。她就是这样创立了特殊奥林匹克运动会。她就是这样在智障人士领域创造了改变。她用意志力将其付诸行动，她踏平了国会山的大厅，当她哥哥是总统时，当她的其他兄弟在参议院时，她强迫他们修改法律。她是毫不妥协的，当她的其他兄弟在参议院时，她强迫他们修改法律，她是毫不妥协的，这创造了巨大的改变。
So I kind of watched that, and I tried to figure out, okay, how do I do that out of the House, but not in the House? Now, I'm sure you've answered this a thousand times. I apologize for not knowing the answer, but what was the main thing that kept you from ever really formally going into a political position and the feeling that you could affect change
所以我看着这一切，我试着去琢磨，好吧，我怎么能在家族大厦之外做到这一点，而不是在家族大厦之内？现在，我确信你已经回答过这个问题一千遍了。如果不知道答案，我深表歉意，但究竟是什么主要原因阻止了你真正正式踏入政坛，以及让你觉得你可以通过私营部门带来更多的改变？
a little bit more from the private sector? Well, my experience with politics was assassination. And I also, my dad ran for vice president in 72 and lost and it was a big, that was a huge watershed moment for me. And I also watched people come over to our home who were involved in politics, who were one way in our house and a different way on television and outside and I didn't like that.
好吧，我对政治的经历是暗杀。而且我也，我爸爸在72年竞选副总统却输了，这对我和我来说是一个巨大的分水岭时刻。而且我也看着那些参与政治的人来到我们家，他们在我们家里是一个样子，但在电视上和外面却是另一个样子，我不喜欢那样。
So for me, it was just, it felt, you know, I felt, and I watched my mother as I said, do things outside of politics and create change and my dad as well started the Peace Corps, the War on Poverty, Head Start, you know, foster grandparents, Job Corps, the list goes on and I watched how they changed the world outside of running for office.
所以对我来说，这感觉，你知道，我觉得，正如我所说，我看着我母亲在政治之外做事并创造改变，我爸爸也是，创立了和平队、向贫困宣战、启蒙计划（Head Start）、祖父母志愿计划、就业团，名单长得很，我看着他们如何在竞选公职之外改变世界。
And so I thought, you know, that was a good model to emulate. What incredible examples of, like, and using their time and their position and, Jay, how many days a week did you play golf last week? Oh, boy. I can tell you, first of all, let me me say I was very peaceful while I did it. Okay, good for you.
所以我想，你知道，这是一个很好的效仿榜样。多么不可思议的榜样，比如利用他们的时间和地位，杰伊，你上周打了几天的尔夫球？哦，天哪。我告诉你，首先，我要说我打球时非常平静。好吧，为你高兴。
Okay, I'm the core of what I was doing. I don't think that's what the peace core means. Yeah, they put a P on the end of it for some weird reason. I was actually talking to my 18 year old yesterday about, oh no, it was the 12 year old, can't remember, one of the daughters yesterday, about service right after school and how some countries make that a requirement.
好吧，我是我所做事情的核心。我不认为和平队是这个意思。对，他们在后面加了个P，出于某种奇怪的原因。我昨天其实还在跟我18岁的孩子聊，哦不，是12岁的孩子，记不清了，昨天跟其中一个女儿聊过，关于放学后的服兵役问题，以及为什么有些国家将其设为强制性的。
And where do you sit on that? I feel like it'd be such a great thing. Someone was talking about it on TV the other day about how it would foster this great healthy sense of shared responsibility. Should it be military service? No, it could take any form. Yeah, in some countries it's military,
对此你怎么看？我觉得这会是一件很棒的事。前几天有人在电视上谈论它，说它将培养出一种伟大的、健康的共同责任感。这应该是服兵役吗？不，它可以采取任何形式。对，在某些国家是军事服役，
in other countries it's just serving the greater good, some sort of civil, Peace Corps came to mind when I was talking to her, that's what made me think of it when you were talking about it. Where's your, where do you stand on that? Sean, you did Up With People for two years, didn't you? I did Down With People.
在其他国家则只是为更广大的福祉服务，某种国民服务，我跟她聊的时候想到了和平队，当你谈到这个时，就是它让我想起了这事。你对这个的立场是什么？西恩，你参加过“同舟共济”（Up With People）两年，对吧？我参加的是“逆流而上”（Down With People）。
I think it's a great idea. I think it's a great idea. We actually in this weekly, I heard you asking about newsletters and I have a newsletter that goes out every Sunday called the Sunday Paper. And we actually published yesterday this op-ed from these two friends of mine, John Bridgeland and Alan Casey,
我觉得这是个好主意。我觉得这是个好主意。我们实际上在这个每周，我听说你问过关于时事通讯的事，我有一个每周日发出的时事通讯叫《周日报》（The Sunday Paper）。我们昨天实际上发表了我的两个朋友约翰·布里奇兰（John Bridgeland）和艾伦·凯西（Alan Casey）写的一篇专栏文章，
called Big Citizenship. And the idea about proposing to this administration about what we actually need is a big service corps where everybody could be of service to their country for one or two years. And you could be in AmeriCorps, you could be in Teach for America, you could be in the Peace Corps.
叫做《伟大的公民身份》（Big Citizenship）。其核心理念是向本届政府提议，我们真正需要的是一个大型服务军团，每个人都可以为自己的国家服务一到两年。你可以加入美国国家服务队（AmeriCorps），可以加入“为美国而教”（Teach for America），也可以加入和平队。
And actually, when Arnold was governor and I was First Lady, we tried to do that. We started a California Corps of people volunteering for California. And I always felt that that would be something that people would bring people from all walks of life together. And I worked for a while on a National Service Corps proposal which never got off the ground but
其实，当阿诺德当州长、我是第一夫人时，我们曾试图这样做。我们启动了一个加州志愿服务军团。我一直觉得这将是一项能把各行各业的人聚集在一起的事业。我曾一度致力于一项国家服务军团的提案，但从未付诸实施，不过
You know, it's a financial. I think it's more of a financial Issue for the federal government. I think there's tremendous desire there that people really want and would Whether it's a gap year And that there's so many ways to be you could have an environmental core They have that in California environmental core corps. I tried to do that, because we need so many more caregivers for people with Alzheimer's and dementia, Parkinson's and all this sort of stuff.
你知道，这是一个财务问题。我认为对联邦政府来说这更多是一个财务问题。我认为那里有着巨大的渴望，人们真的很想要并且会——无论是间隔年（gap year），而且有那么多服务方式，你可以建立一个环保军团。他们在加州有这样的环保军团。我试图这样做，因为我们需要更多照顾阿尔茨海默症、痴呆症、帕金森病等等病患的护理人员。
If people went, could they get free tuition if they went to a state school, if they gave two years to be a caregiver. Coming out. Yeah. JB, when they canceled Hogan family, didn't you have a gap year? Oh yeah, yeah, more of a decade.
如果人们去的话，如果他们为成为护理人员付出两年时间，他们去州立大学就能免学费吗？刚出来的时候。对。JB，当他们取消《霍根一家》（Hogan Family）时，你难道没有一个间隔年吗？哦对，对，更像是一个十年。
You don't remember it. But yeah, it would be, not to be too cynical, but it does seem like the miracle of it all, or the big thing that would get it moving, would be what is the carrot on the other side for the person who's volunteering, quote unquote. Like is it free tuition, is it a more favored consideration on your application going into a state school?
你不记得了。不过对，这会是——倒不是说要太愤世嫉俗，但这确实看起来像是一个奇迹，或者能让它真正运转起来的决定性因素，在于对那个所谓的自愿者来说，另一头究竟有什么胡萝卜（好处）。比如是免费学费，还是在申请州立大学时能获得更多优待？
What's in it for them aside from the good feeling you would have? Well that would be big to get tuition lessened. That's, I think that's a huge carrot for people who have student loans waived. Or just a higher consideration, a different list that you're on when you're considering for a state school because I know my 18 year old,
除了内心的良好感觉之外，对他们有什么好处？嗯，减免学费这绝对算是个大头。我觉得，对于能够免除学生贷款的人来说，这绝对是一根巨大的胡萝卜。或者仅仅是获得更多优先考虑，当你申请州立大学时处于一个不同的候选名单上，因为我知道我18岁的孩子，
that's so much anxiety for kids, like getting into a school, have I done enough extracurricular, blah, blah, blah. Like if that was something that like, oh, you go right to the top of the list in consideration for these UC schools, that would be big and it wouldn't cost,
这对孩子们来说有太多的焦虑了，比如能不能考上大学，我做的课外活动够不够，等等等等。如果这能变成一种，比如，哦，你在申请加州大学系统（UC）时可以直接排在候选名单的最顶端，那可就太了不起了，而且这不会花，
I don't think it would cost the state anything. We tried to do something like that. I was chairing a task force for the governor here on Alzheimer's and that was one of our recommendations about that, so it hadn't happened yet. But I think there are ideas like that around, which I think are great. And I think that young people would really like that. Service Corps, there are some programs around like that,
我觉得这不会让州里花什么钱。我们曾试图做过类似的事情。我当时在这里担任州长阿尔茨海默症工作组的主席，那是我们的建议之一，所以它还没有发生。但我认为周围有这样的好主意，我觉得这很棒。而且我认为年轻人会真的很喜欢它。服务军团，周围有一些这样的项目，
but I think the question always is, they don't pay well, obviously. Right, right, right. But you're at an age where you don't need the money just yet, like you might still potentially be under your parents' wing, you know, just right after high school and before college, and maybe the parents would be okay giving one more year of support
但我认为问题总在于，它们的薪水显然不高。对，对，对。但你正处于还不需要钱的年纪，你可能还在父母的羽翼之下，你知道，就在高中毕业之后、上大学之前，也许父母会愿意再提供一年的支持，
while you're off helping the country or the state. Yeah, well, yeah, a lot of people do need the money. So it's like looking at, so that it's a diverse workforce, that it's, you know, different states have different needs, right, different states have different needs. And so I think it's a great idea. There are a lot of people who've been pushing it for a long time, it has not happened.
当你去帮助国家或州里的时候。好吧，是的，很多人确实需要钱。所以这就需要兼顾，确保这是一支多元化的劳动力队伍，你知道，不同的州有不同的需求，对吧，不同的州有不同的需求。所以我认为这是一个好主意。有很多人长期以来一直在推动它，但它一直没有发生。
I thought it was an intriguing op-ed that these guys wrote, originally for the Washington Post last week, and then we repurposed it in the Sunday paper on Sunday. I want that newsletter. Big citizenship, I like that idea, big citizenship. Yeah, you know, it's funny, I mean, we sit here, we talk about it and it's, you know,
我觉得这篇专栏文章很吸引人，这几位仁兄上周最初为《华盛顿邮报》写的，然后我们在周日的《周日报》上进行了重新刊登。我想要那份时事通讯。大公民身份，我喜欢这个想法，大公民身份。是的，你知道，这很有趣，我是说，我们坐在这里，我们谈论它，而且，
we're in a unique position, we get to sort of talk about these ideas, et cetera, and they make a lot of sense. And how funny or how unfortunate is it? As you say, there's met resistance, it never happened, it wouldn't go through. And it really does make you wonder, why? Yeah, why not?
我们处于一个独特的地位，我们得以谈论这些想法等等，而且它们非常有道理。这又是多么有趣或多么不幸呢？正如你所说，它遇到了阻力，它从未发生过，它根本通不过。这确实让人不禁想问，为什么？对，为什么不呢？
That's what I was wondering. Why don't people want to do it? Why don't people, why isn't there a sense that we should do something for the greater good? And people go, well, we don't want to. Yeah, or a couple of people don't want to. Well, there's a lot going on actually. Like I look at Special Olympics all the time,
这也是我一直在想的。为什么人们不想做这件事？为什么人们，为什么没有一种我们应该为更广泛的福祉做点什么的感觉？而人们会说，我们不想。好吧，或者有那么几个人不想。好吧，其实有很多事情在发生。比如我一直看着特殊奥林匹克运动会，
which is one of the largest volunteer programs in the world, right? And people are from both parties, from all different age groups go out and volunteer. And I think because they're asked, they're asked like this program won't succeed in your neighborhood or your community or your state unless you volunteer.
这是世界上最大的志愿者项目之一，对吧？来自两党、各个年龄段的人都出来做志愿者。我想是因为他们被邀请了，他们被邀请了，就像这个项目如果在你的街区、你的社区或你的州里，除非你当志愿者，否则就不会成功。
And I think sometimes people, depends who's doing the asking, right? You even see that in our own homes, you know? Sometimes like, who's asking you to clear the table? Who's asking you to do the chore? And then what figure is asking you to be of service? And I think we, young people aren't volunteering for military corps because sometimes they look and see,
我觉得有时候人们，这取决于谁在发出邀请，对吧？你甚至在我们自己的家里也能看到这一点，你知道吗？有时候，比如，是谁让你收拾桌子的？是谁让你做家务的？然后又是哪个形象在呼吁你为大家服务？而且我认为我们，年轻人之所以不肯加入军事军团，是因为有时他们看着会想，
like, well how does that person get taken care of when they come back? Who's doing the asking? What is the life like on the other end versus, you know, many years ago, right? So I think it's, I believe that, you know, if the right person raises it up, puts it front and center,
比如，那个人回来后是如何被照顾的？是谁在发出邀请？另一头的的生活是什么样的，相比于，你知道，许多年前，对吧？所以我认为，我相信，如果合适的人把它提出来，把它放在最显眼、最中心的位置，
makes it inspiring, calls young people up and tells them we need you in order to rebuild the country, in order to put our values front and center, in order that you can have a country that's gonna be the country you wanna live in with the values you wanna live in. So I'm calling everybody up. I mean, I think it's,
让它具有启发性，召唤年轻人并告诉他们，为了重建国家，为了把我们的价值观放在最前沿，为了让你们能拥有一个你们想在其中生活、拥有你们想要的价值观的国家，我们需要你们。所以我在此呼吁所有人。我是说，我觉得，
nobody's called people up like that, right? It's great. One of the pieces of advice I've actually shared with these guys before outside of this podcast is anytime there'd be an issue that came up politically or socially or whatever it was, and I would complain about it to you, and you would say, I know, isn't that awful?
从来没有人这样呼吁过大家，对吧？太棒了。我实际上在这个播客之外跟这几位分享过的一条建议是，每当有政治上、社会上或其他什么问题出现时，我会向你抱怨，而你会说，我知道，这不是很糟糕吗？
So what are you doing about it? Yeah, exactly. And I'm like, oh, and it completely disarms people, because you're right, it's like to everything you're saying, you have to be the leader of that, instead of sitting and waiting for somebody to ask you. Well, I think kids would listen to you if you just ask them to serve.
所以你为此做了什么？对，完全正确。而我会想，哦，这完全卸下了人们的防备，因为你说得对，就像你所说的一切一样，你必须成为那件事的领导者，而不是坐在那里等着别人来求你。好吧，我觉得如果你只是要求孩子们去服务，他们会听你的。
Me? You think they'd listen to me? I think they would, yeah. So wait, so Maria. I love that, I mean, I think Jason, you should take that on. I think like my kids, if you ask my kids, they pay attention. They'd be like, did you hear it?
我？你觉得他们会听我的？我觉得会的，所以等等，玛丽亚。我喜欢这样，我是说，我觉得杰伊，你应该承担起这个责任。我觉得就像我的孩子们，如果你要求我的孩子们，他们会注意的。他们会觉得，你听到了吗？
God, he asked us to be of service. I think Will has a better voice. Will makes a lot of money with his voice, a lot of timber to it. I'll set him up with a big phone bank. I'll get him all the numbers. We'll send a car to get you out of the house. Will, I think you're uniquely suited for this.
天哪，他要求我们为大家服务。我觉得威尔的声音更好听。威尔用他的声音赚了很多钱，有很强的磁性。我给他安排一个大型电话呼叫中心。我帮他弄到所有的号码。我们派辆车把你接出家门。威尔，我觉得你特别适合这个。
You got a whisper booth there. Everything's all ready. So Maria, before we leave you. You're leaving? Yeah, but it's an hour. You're already in the overtime. I'm going to go tell the leaf blower he can go back, right? Yes, but wait, I have one last thing. One last thing.
你在那儿有个隔音室。一切都准备就绪了。所以玛丽亚，在我们告别你之前。你要走了？对，但已经一小时了。你已经进入加时赛了。我要去告诉那个吹树叶的工人他可以回去了，对吧？是的，不过等等，我还有最后一件事。最后一件事。
You've super successful. You've seen it all. You've met everyone. You've had more experiences than anyone I know. What is it there? What is it that you haven't done or want to accomplish that speaks to your values? How about that?
你非常成功。你什么都见过。你什么人都见过了。你的经历比我认识的任何人都多。还有什么？有什么是你还没做过或者想要实现、并且符合你的价值观的？这个怎么样？
Oh, that's a really deep question. Yeah. Wow. Yeah. Should have gave her that at the beginning and give her a chance to come up with an answer. I don't know if I'm going to tell you the answer. I know the answer, but I'm not going to tell you this.
哦，这是一个非常深刻的问题。对。哇。对。你应该在一开始就抛出这个问题，给她一个想出答案的机会。我不知道我是否会告诉你答案。我知道答案，但我不会告诉你这个。
Really? Yeah, oh, I know the answer. Come on, Maria. No, no, not going to say it. You're not going to tell us what you. I'm just gonna keep on going. I'm gonna keep on going right down here. I totally am always thinking of like.
真的吗？对，哦，我知道答案。得了吧，玛丽亚。不，不，我不会说的。你不会告诉我们你。我只是要继续前行。我这就一直往前走。我绝对会的。
You're pointing in the right direction, yes? I'm pointing in the right direction. Yes, that's true, you are. I'm moving forward. You are. I think and I always tell you, I think like who do I want at my 70th birthday? Who do I want at my funeral?
你指的方向是正确的，对吗？我指的方向是正确的。是的，确实如此，你是。我在向前迈进。你是。我觉得而且我总是对你说的，我觉得像，我想让谁参加我的70岁生日？我想让谁参加我的葬礼？
And I work on those relationships now. I love that those are two different lists. I love it, I love it. And I'm now gonna include you to the other boys now at my funeral and my birthday party. I just grew my list. That's right. I'd love to say a few words if that'd be okay.
我现在就在经营这些关系。我喜欢这两份不同的名单。我太喜欢了，太喜欢了。我现在要把你们这些小伙子也加入到我葬礼和生日派对的名单里了。我的名单刚刚变长了。没错。如果可以的话，我很乐意说几句。
I hope so, I hope you'll bring a poem because I've got this book of poetry. That's mainly when people use poems, right? They stand up at a funeral, they stand up at a wedding. I asked to get the copy of the book and it's not ready yet, but I can't wait to read I Am Maria and the Poems. And then a poem.
希望如此，希望你能带上一首诗，因为我有这本诗集。这主要是人们在用诗的时候，对吧？他们在葬礼上起立，他们在婚礼上起立。我要求得到这本书的副本，但还没准备好，但我迫不及待地想读《我是玛丽亚与诗歌》。然后是一首诗。
Do you have a poem in your life that's important? Nothing. No, Roses Are Red, Valleys Are Blue. Nothing, how about you other guys? No poems, no poetry? I gotta work on that. I mean, I could cite like, you know, Rilke or somebody like that, you know what I mean?
你的生活中有一首重要的诗吗？没有。没有，玫瑰是红的，山谷是蓝的。没有，你们其他人呢？没有诗，没有诗歌？我得在这方面下点功夫。我是说，我可以引用，你知道的，里尔克（Rilke）或类似的人，你知道我的意思吗？
Jeez. I mean, what are we gonna do? Poetry is useful in times of celebration, in times of heartbreak. So you don't want to answer the one thing that you haven't done that you wanna accomplish. Well, but you made it specifically to her values. Now, she could, you could say something
天哪。我是说，我们要怎么办？诗歌在庆祝的时刻、在心碎的时刻都很有用。所以你不想回答那件你还没做过、但你想实现的唯一事情吗？好吧，但你刚才把它具体限定在她的价值观上了。现在，你可以，你可以说点
a little bit more trivial, like, is there a place you'd like to go, or a person you've yet to meet? Yeah, how about that? Oh, yeah, I have a person I'd yet to meet. I really wanna meet, sit and have a meal with the pope. Ah-ha. I really wanna meet meet and sit and have a meal with the Pope. I really want to meet the Pope. I want to move in with the Pope.
更琐碎的事情，比如，有没有什么你想去的地方，或者你还没见过的人？对，这个怎么样？哦，对，我确实有一个还没见过的人。我真的很想见见教皇，坐下来和他吃顿饭。啊哈。我真的很想见见教皇，坐下来和他吃顿饭。我真的很想见教皇。我想搬去和教皇一起住。
I want to hang with the Pope. He's pretty jammed, I'm looking right now. He is, yeah. I mean, how's your April? How's your April looking? I'll change, I'll even give up my Sunday dinner for the Pope. Let me talk, okay.
我想和教皇厮混。他行程挺满的，我正在查。是的，他确实。我是说，你四月过得怎么样？你四月看起来怎么样？我会改变计划，为了教皇我甚至可以放弃我的周日晚餐。让我说，好吧。
I'll move everything around for the Pope. For Francis, yeah, he's my man. I feel like you can make that happen. All right, I'm going to work on that for you. Will you work on that for me? Just put me in your luggage, take me there to Rome. I think if I could just get in and sit down at the table, you're not allowed, my brother went there,
为了教皇我什么都可以调动。为了方济各，对，他是我的菜。我觉得你能让这事发生。好吧，我会为你争取这个的。你会为我争取这个吗？只要把我塞进行李箱，带我去罗马。我想如果我能进去并在桌旁坐下，这是不允许的，我哥哥去过那里，
and you're not, if you see him eating there, you're not allowed to go over and talk. And so my brother said, well, you would break that rule, Maria, I said, oh, for sure. For sure. Let me just say this, Maria. Maria, let me just say this. If anyone can, the Vatican.
你是不允许的，如果你看到他在那里吃饭，你是不被允许走过去说话的。所以我哥哥说，好吧，玛丽亚，你会打破这个规矩的，我说，哦，肯定会。绝对会。让我这么说吧，玛丽亚。玛丽亚，让我这么说吧。如果有人能做到，那就是梵蒂冈。
Okay, so don't worry. There we go. There it is. Oh, that's funny, the Vatican. There we go. Okay. Maria, we love you. I can't wait for your book.
好吧，所以不用担心。就是这样。就是它。哦，这太有趣了，梵蒂冈。就是这样。好吧。玛丽亚，我们爱你。我等不及看你的书了。
I love you, Shani. Yeah, so much. Thank you. One of the most important people in my life is you, as well as these two fellas. So I'm all in one show. It makes me very, very happy to be here. Really nice to meet you. Thank you for having me.
我也爱你，肖尼。是的，非常爱。谢谢你。我生命中最重要的人之一就是你，还有这两个家伙。所以我全情投入这场节目。这让我感到非常非常高兴。很高兴认识你。谢谢你邀请我。
Thank you for having me. Thank you, Maria. I want to come over and clear the table. Invite me, I'll be a good guest. Yeah, and you don't have to ask him, he'll just do it. He'll do it? Yeah, yeah. Love it.
谢谢你邀请我。谢谢你，玛丽亚。我想过去收拾桌子。邀请我吧，我会是个好客人的。对，你不用开口求他，他自己就会干。他会干？对，对。太棒了。
Good example for my boys. All right, honey, love you. Okay, bye. Thanks, Maria. Now do I go'll just do it. He'll do it? Yeah, yeah, love it. Good example for my boys. All right, honey, love you. Okay, bye, now do I go? Thank you. You slam it. Yeah. You can slam it shut. Yeah.
给我儿子们树立个好榜样。好了，亲爱的，爱你。好的，拜拜。谢谢你，玛丽亚。现在我是不是该走——他自己就会干。他会干？对，对，太棒了。给我儿子们树立个好榜样。好了，亲爱的，爱你。好的，拜拜，现在我是不是该走了？谢谢。你把它摔上。对。你可以把它“砰”地关上。对。
Right? Doesn't she feel better? She's emotional, emotional, so bright. I've met her a couple times with you, but so briefly, and I never really got a sense of like how, I mean, a little bit, she's obviously super smart. But like, she's amazing. And 10, I mean, there's 10,000 other things
对吧？她是不是感觉好多了？她很情绪化，情绪化，太聪明的。我和你一起见过她好几次，但都太短暂了，我从未真正感受到她——我是说，有一点，她显然超级聪明。但像，她太棒了。而且一万个，我是说，还有一万件其他事情
that she's started or programs, or I mean, we didn't even get into any of it, but she's endless. Every single day she wakes up thinking about how she can serve. And we talked about that before with other people, but how can she- Don't sell yourself short.
她发起的事情或项目，我是说，我们甚至都没深入探讨任何一项，但她简直是个无底洞。她每天醒来都在思考她能如何服务。我们之前跟其他人也讨论过这个，但她怎么能——别看轻了你自己。
You told me the other day you started season four the mentalist. That's true. You and Scottie. The mentalist. How do you have that at the ready? The mentalist. Anyway, Maria, Maria, Maria.
你前几天跟我说你开始看第四季的《超感神探》（The mentalist）了。真的。你和斯科蒂。《超感神探》。你怎么能随时随地掏出这个？《超感神探》。不管怎样，玛丽亚，玛丽亚，玛丽亚。
I love Sean, I love that. I know you've talked so fondly about her and her family and how important they are to you and your life. Yeah. Right, and just like, well, because he doesn't like, does not like to cook. That is why. No, but like real-
我爱西恩，我喜欢那样。我知道你经常深情地谈论她和她的家人，以及他们对你和你的生活有多么重要。对。没错，就像，好吧，因为他不喜欢，非常讨厌做饭。这就是原因。不，但真正的——
Jen's on Sunday, Maria's on Thursday. Real rocks, real rocks for you. Like really, real, right? Oh, thanks, Eddie. Yeah, thanks. Like a real steadiness added to your life. She is, yeah. As are you guys, by the way.
詹娜周日来，玛丽亚周四来。真正的基石，对你来说是真正的基石。就像真的，真的，对吧？哦，谢谢，埃迪。对，谢谢。就像给你的生活增添了一份真正的稳定感。她是的，对。你们也是，顺便说一句。
Oh, thanks. Yeah, but. Yeah, she's done so much for so many groups, hearing her talk, and it's just incredible. Anyway, thanks for indulging, and I'm glad you enjoyed her as much as I did. She seems like she would be absolutely my favorite person
哦，谢谢。对，但是。是的，她为那么多群体做了那么多事，听她说话，这简直不可思议。不管怎样，感谢你们的纵容，我很高兴你们和一样我一样喜欢她。她看起来绝对会是我最喜欢的人
in the world. Well why don't we do, we'll do a din. Yeah, make it happen. We'll do a din? Yeah, that's short for dinner. Yeah, we'll do a dinty. This guy's a hip guy. He's got Riz.
在世界上。那我们为什么不搞一个，我们搞个聚餐。对，把它办成。我们搞个聚餐？对，那是晚餐（dinner）的简称。对，我们搞个聚餐。这家伙是个潮人。他很有魅力（Riz）。
I'm trying to think. Riz, Riz, Riz. Sean, anything in the bi folder? There we go, he's got the bi folder. I don't want to pull up the bi folder. Put on your bifocals and anything there. You know, we watched... Oh yeah, go ahead.
我在想。魅力，魅力，魅力。西恩，双焦点眼镜盒里有什么吗？来了，他拿着双焦点眼镜盒呢。我可不想掏出双焦点眼镜盒。戴上你的双焦点眼镜，看看里面有什么。你知道，我们看了……哦，对，请便。
Here we go. This is a made up story. Oh, you know, we watched a show last night and... Oh, I used this one before. I used this one before. You know, I like to, if I'm driving around and I'm hungry and it's a Sunday and Maria's having family dinner, I like to stop... Bye for a quick...
来吧。这是一个虚构的故事。哦，你知道，我们昨晚看了一个节目，然后……哦，我以前用过这个。我以前用过这个。你知道，我喜欢，如果我在开车转悠而且我饿了，正好是星期天，玛丽亚在举行家庭晚宴，我喜欢顺便过去……顺便来个快捷的……
Bye. All right, bye. Quick bite and bye everybody. Bye. Bye. Bye. Fuck, we are scraping the bottom. Smart.
拜拜。好的，拜拜。快速吃一口，然后大家拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。操，我们真是在江郎才尽了。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armgerve, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
简史。聪明。简史。《聪明简史》由罗伯·阿姆格维、本尼特·巴比科和迈克尔·格兰特·特里100%有机手工制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。